[Music]  my first 100 days as president have been  difficult  I lost my husband we were about to  celebrate 30 years together your husband  and I had an agreement Francis is dead  promises were made not by me  here's the thing whatever Francis told  you the last five years don't believe a  word of it the reign of the middle-aged  white men is over you thought you got  away with it all Claire but that remains  to be seen the bodies are ready now this  is my house and I want you out all I  want you to do is behave as promised did  you think you'd seen the last of me I'm  not going to be told what's doing here  it's not like a gangster Madame  president  the world is either with us or against  us the president scares me we've got to  get this woman out of there it's going  to be different for you and me  [Music]  you  you